[Music]
and they're gone wrong news dare like
the program yes sir
submitted by roads from London a 27 year
old died eight years after unknowingly
eating an infected slug on a dare
what the hell eight years eight years it
took that long is it one of those slugs
with a parasite inside it and in the
[ __ ] parasite which was brain is that
like you ain't gum and take seven years
of the digest cut [ __ ] it's just not
true pal
well I know exactly yes I'm saying that
parasites called the rat lungworm that's
what do you cuz I thought I had that
okay oh [ __ ] I could still die in eight
years
yep that's [ __ ] crazy how many years
are you on hurry up and become rich and
put us in your wealth two years will
happen you're only two years hey you
know I like to swim in Hawaii in the and
the crystal-clear waters under the
waterfall Oh Minnetonka we know cuz it
heals me so I'll swim it like a
[ __ ] gargling and [ __ ] like this
is gonna heal me right
and I went upstream and I saw dead
[ __ ] rat in the creek and I was like
oh there's some bad rats post some
pictures on Instagram and people are
like be careful for the rat lungworm and
I was like what the [ __ ] is that I look
it up it's a parasite that lives inside
slugs and [ __ ] rats and it goes into
the brain of rats and it controls them
like a [ __ ] brain parasite and
then it [ __ ] kills them and now I'm
like I got [ __ ] parasites cuz I was
swimming in that water big is this body
of water though it was pretty [ __ ]
big alright then I think you're okay I
hope so
you haven't had in your symptoms damn
that ruined your vacation huh well
probably like like 10 hours after that
[ __ ] happen I read it I was on [ __ ] I
was on [ __ ] wet when WebMD or not not
that long I just went to sleep after but
then like oh that I was trippin like for
a good few hours like I'm gonna [ __ ]
die and I was like you know what but if
I'm a die
I'm a [ __ ] die and I went to sleep
and I woke up and then we see everything
you just did is how he is but she's such
a hyper contracted she'd be like I
I am having rat thoughts and I'm like
the [ __ ] is a rat exactly sure like look
it up and because her mind remembers
everything she's going through the
entire database of like all the fat and
I'm just like well [ __ ] it was right but
I I'm like still listening because I
respect and love her but I'm just like
you know what you got to do man next
time she does that all you all you got
to do put in a sleeper hold knock her
the [ __ ] out oh really quick just what
if I'm on a Hawaiian beach and people
see me just put her in a sleeper hold
knock her out
it was drag her away oh she's a
hypochondriac no you just do it like in
a loving way give her kisses I love you
so much it was like you're hugging her
that's good then she just lays on the
beach she's not so she wakes up she's
like what happened oh you could pretend
like you're dancing to oh that's
actually better is falling you you know
what I pictured is little parasites
coming into my brain and then like
[ __ ] like working on it like like
they're working in a coal mine and then
they're like readjusting [ __ ] and then
we got like somebody that looks like
crane from Ninja Turtles you know the
brain that lives inside the belly I saw
that [ __ ] like taken over and
then making me do like irrational rat
things you know I will say this I think
you actually do have it that dude I
think it's actually yeah something
happened dude I wouldn't mind being
taken over and doing rational rat things
but do you know what do you but think
about that first night yeah okay never
mind that's what I was being arguments
all the time I thought it [ __ ] I thought
about it before I said it and I'm like
that's pretty cool cuz then I could have
like an out-of-body experience we're
like I'm randomly in like a cheese
factory and I'm like wait what am I
doing here my oh three rats [ __ ] tight
this is giving me rap memories like cuz
it's eight years and I'm thinking like
[ __ ] it could still happen
wait I don't know frustrating right now
I don't know everything is flu-like
symptoms and everything is like
irritability and the same symptoms and
[ __ ] to a rattle cod react
[Laughter]
you can't escape it even if he wanted to
rats and you're dating a hood rat yeah
kidding I love each other no I mean he's
a right at tubing all right so this man
this young man is from Australia
his name is Sam so back when he was 19
years old in 2010 he was drinking with
his friends and then they were just
sitting there drinking some wine and
then that's when a slug came crawling
across and one of his friends said like
dared him to eat it
and so he was like should I eat it and
that's um Australia's [ __ ] like [ __ ]
so he ate it and then that's when hot
Dave it's no Mike that's so stupid
he died telling the story all right they
gotta get a photo of him like in
Southeast Asia or some [ __ ] on vacation
why it looks like he's at a Cambodian
hotel lounge Wow dude yeah I mean just
look in the back in the background parts
pervert face on the right the one that
you make when you're doing something
perverted like yeah yeah oh he died a
young kid I'm sad yeah so what ended up
happening is like he didn't get sick
immediately and but then he started
complaining of leg pain and so doctors
tested him for multiple sclerosis
because that's what his father suffers
from and but then they rolled that out
and then he kept like he was told his
mom that he did eat a worm but she like
kind of brushed it off like mom's not
gonna know she's like no one gets sick
from that
but then that parents are [ __ ] dumb
you don't say your parents anything yeah
so then doctors kept testing on four
more things and they finally found out
that he contracted a rat lungworm which
like joe said it's found in rodents and
paralyzes human beings Jesus yeah and so
it affects the brain and spinal cord
and it left him with this really long
medical thing I'm not gonna try to
pronounce and so he ends up oh man
Candida being like this oh he's kind of
like paralyzed a little bit pretty much
oh my god well the thing is that thing
that he contracted they so he was in a
coma for four hundred and twenty days
that's over a year he woke up with brain
damage and so that's like when he was
like paralyzed but that was like this
one point where he was recovering but
that's what do you fell into this coma
because a lot like apparently people do
get better from the thing that he got
the time he just got worse yeah there's
some people that come back from it but
then they still suffer from like like
headaches or brain [ __ ] afterwards
Jesus yeah it's it's a pretty crazy ass
like condition man once they find out
that you have it there's no cure for it
it's kind of like your [ __ ] you just
have to wait till the end comes no so
people do yeah they do recover but it's
just that for him and just do this it
depends on you know yeah it's it's like
cancer right like it depends on how far
it is it's like if they multiply the
parasites are just all over depends on
people's health their immune system so
if it's stupid ass mob didn't go oh you
don't get sick from worms she's not a
stupid ass mom you don't think that you
would get sick from eating I would have
bet you don't get sick someone okay fine
yeah my stupid ass well yeah my
super-awesome how much I asked somebody
about I don't know dude daddy's done
think about how long no it's like oh
that was a year ago it's like damn you
don't mean like it oh yeah yeah yeah you
don't that's true you don't know
timeframe to share that that's true
that's tripod be like eat some sriracha
oh kill the things inside Wow you know
mama stupid I know I'm dumb when I was
reading that [ __ ] like it was like
symptoms don't appear sometimes until
like way later exactly because it takes
time for that parasite to get to your
brain
and then it took all this time slower to
get David right now a couple years yo
you know there's people that get rat
lungworm from just eating salad because
oh god yeah so I forgot if it comes from
the slug or it comes from the rat but
you know maybe it comes from the slug
because the rat eats the slug in the in
the rat or the you tell me this is the
sentence disease found in rodents that
can also infect snails and slugs through
the larvae and their feces I'll compile
right yeah okay so it comes that's why
okay and then but the slugs will will
have the snail trails and [ __ ] on the
lettuce and leaves and then you know you
get that but they're not washed
thoroughly and people get get it through
this will cook your food cook your rats
if you're eating them or whatever that
Jesus washer rats wash your salads yeah
yeah even if the boxes been thoroughly
wash oh she tells me to wash it again
I'm like fine doing yeah oh damn dude
cuz I usually touched them I don't they
said they thoroughly washed it I don't
know if it's here though in the mainland
oh really yeah dude I used to wash
vegetables and fruits by eating it and
then I just drink a glass of water after
I think I think our produce its we're
probably more affected by this
can you really don't cook it no I don't
care anyway to fall at the water yeah
the grocery store they had those misters
and I was like that's [ __ ] Washington
that just keeps it boys
yeah I don't know anything
[Music]